all right folks thank you for your
patience little light getting this to
you but my friend was
in town from out of town and he and i
were hanging out going retro game
shopping things got to be done and life
has to be lived that said there's a
trailer for venom let there be carnage
so things now need to be talked about
the way this trailer starts out like i i
couldn't have called it
if a venom versus carnage movie couldn't
have called how this trailer starts out
that said it's definitely playing up
what worked in venom which was
eddie brock venom the buddy alien movie
but when
young jeremy part of the maximum carnage
fan base had his fingers crossed
with fans around the world hoping for a
venom versus carnage
and spider-man movie but a venom versus
carnage movie i i couldn't recall that
the trailer would start out with eddie
brock looking about us
dead inside as someone who sold their
bitcoin back in 2018
while venom comedically whips him up
breakfast and sings while doing it
excuse me couldn't have called it but
hey venom versus carnage movie
here we are that said woody harrelson
looks great as cletus cassidy glady
doesn't have the weird sideshow bob wig
they definitely were like
let's let's keep it kept little known
secret after natural born killers came
out that was a fan casting woody
harrelson was a fan casting for cletus
cassidy so it's really cool to see that
happen
i miss you so much
yeah cletus cassidy all right smashing a
spider that's right if i can't get
spider-man
in on this battle royale i certainly can
have cletus cassidy smashing
a spider watching this trailer i
couldn't help but get the sense of like
it's my my one thought yeah i'm finally
seeing carnage on screen for the first
time
ever on the big screen or my phone
watching the trailer for a movie that's
going to be on the big screen but my
thought was like
is this going to be pg-13 or r because
we've heard pg-13
then joker crushed in the conversation
kind of switched like well maybe
our it could happen so who knows what
it's going to be i really hope it's
rated r though i don't want to see this
really awesome happen have it cut
away or have the violence take place in
the shadows because they're trying to
hide the blood they're trying to hide
the fact that it's like
venom eats brains carnage brings what's
the word
carnage you know it's in the name
quite literally very on the nose you
don't want to see the breakfast he'd be
making
cletus cassidy in the morning no very
hannibal lecter-esque
from the show hannibal which was on tv
one of the carnage novels forgot if it
was carnegie new york or goblin's
revenge point is it described him
pulling a head off and bowling it like a
soggy football it just kind of bounced
i want to see that i already saw it in
my head because i read it
like the book already gave me that when
i was younger so let's just say it on
the screen i like how carnage busts out
too because
in the comic books and the stories and
the novels and whatnot cletus cassidy
would have
to draw blood in order to bring the
carnage symbiote out so it looks like
that's what they're doing in this movie
because as when he gets that needle poke
for that lethal injection
that's when all hell breaks loose and if
there is a time for cletus cassidy to
bust out and become carnage and escape
i'm glad it's during the lethal
injection what can i say i like it point
is carnage looks pretty awesome though
gonna be real i do like the carnage
design of him having black teeth
rather than white teeth like he has in
this movie but that's just me but all in
all solid first look
and solid brief glimpse i appreciate
that i hope they
keep that up until the movie's release
don't show too much of carnage in the
trailers give us something to look
forward to all right so the trailer for
venom let there be carnage have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you